[Music]
we know that a vibration is nothing but
to-and-fro a back-and-forth motion of
the body in the previous lesson we guess
the basic idea of what produces sound it
is vibration that produces sound so if
we set any body into vibration it will
give us some sound some vibrations we
can clearly see but some we can't
examples are you familiar with this
shape what is it called it's called a
door lock it's a two headed drum a
musical instrument commonly used in
India when you strike any of the two
flat surfaces of the door lock they
start to vibrate and produce sound do
you know what the two flat surfaces of
the doulica called they are called
membranes yes it's a membrane of a Dalek
which produces the sound in musical
instruments like the sitar and the
guitar it is the vibration of strings
went left that reduces the sound these
vibrations are then transferred to the
soundboard which adjusts the loudness of
the sound what about the flute how is
the sound produced in a flute
the vibrations are produced by the air
column when we breathe into its mouth
hole the air inside the flute starts
vibrating and we hear the sound do you
hear the buzzing when a mosquito is
close to your ears ever wondered how
that sound is made the sound is because
of flapping of wings by a mosquito yes
the wings of mosquito are vibrating and
it's this vibration that reduces the
buzz we hear let us do one experiment
take a string hold both at the end in
your hands like this stretch the strings
such that it does not form any curves in
the middle now tell your friend to pluck
the string from the center do you see
the string vibrating yes the string
vibrates and you'd probably have heard
some sound too let us do one more
experiment take a frying pan strike the
pan with the spoon like this
do you hear sound yes you do but do you
see the pan or spoon vibrating not
really but you could feel the spoon
vibrating in your hand if you touch the
pan immediately after the strike you
will feel that the pan is also vibrating
wait for the vibrations to stop and then
pour some water into the pan we see that
nothing happens to the water now strike
the pan again do you see something
strange now these strange things are
called
waves they are generated because of the
vibration in the pan
so there are some vibrations that we are
able to see and some vibrations that we
can only feel in this video we saw that
vibrations produce sound but before we
sign off here are some interesting
questions for you to think about can
sound travel through solids or perhaps
liquids can you think of some example in
which sound travels through liquids to
find out the answers to these questions
you have to watch our next video see you
then
[Music]